All right.
At this
moment,
hundreds of thousands of protest
are on the streets of Paris.
We just learned
the police have stopped demonstr
as they reach the constitutional
kind of equivalent to the Suprem
CNN's Frederik
Pleitgen is right
in the middle of it all.
Fred, if you can hear me.
Tell us what you're seeing
Hi there, John.
Well, in the last couple
of minutes, things
have actually kicked off here in
We saw some
clashes happening
between the riot police here
and some of the protesters
Still only
a very small part of the protest
It certainly seems
as though
most of it is still very peacefu
However, we did see some big cla
going on here
a couple of minutes ago with the
deploying tear
gas, even
beating some of the protesters
as well, charging the crowd,
whereas the protesters then answ
by throwing bottles
and rocks at the cops.
So that is something that's goin
If you look at the scene right n
it is still pretty tense around
We're sort of in an area right n
that's between two layers of pol
It's sort of gone back a little
But there is a lot of tension
in the air here.
And as you can see,
there's still some bangs
that are going off as well.
So certainly
this march one
that has gone from one
that has been very peaceful
from the beginning to
not so much right now.
Again, the protesters who,
of course, very angry
at that pension reform
that Emmanuel Macron
has been trying to essentially b
through the legislative process
And I think one of the interesti
that you guys see
if you can around,
you can see that a lot of the fo
who are coming to protest,
they are actually fairly
young people who are protesting
So to them,
of course, it's about the pensio
It's about raising the pension a
but it is also about the way
that Emmanuel Macron
has tried
to do this, using executive powe
to try and push all of this thro
That's something a lot of people
don't take very well.
And it certainly has damaged
him, as you can see, considerabl
Politically.
It has also damaged
the political system
here in this country.
There are some
who say that
it's essentially the far right
that is benefiting from the fact
that there's
so much criticism of the governm
right now.
As you can see,
there's still some banks
going off behind me, John.
Yeah. Flashbangs smoke bombs.
We've seen
gas there over the last few week
Fred, there is a court
decision expected tomorrow.
The reason I ask
that is these protests tend to g
as the evening goes on. It's abo
local time where you are.
Is there a sense that today
in the tonight
you could see some of the worst
of the protests and demonstratio
we've seen
because the legal avenues
may have dried up
and
Yeah, I think that I think that'
that's a pretty fair assessment
that that is something that coul
You do feel
that there are a lot of people
here on the street.
A lot of anger here
on the street as well.
And I think that people really f
that this is really
the last sort of moment
that they have to try
and get that message out.
You're absolutely right.
Tomorrow evening, local time, ob
the Constitutional Council of th
country is going to decide
whether this law is constitution
or whether all of it or parts of
are not constitutional.
Obviously, that's a very,
very important moment for the fo
But a lot of the people
we've been speaking
to are also saying no matter
what the constitutional council
they are going to keep protestin
because they are so angry
at the government.
And really,
if you look at this right now,
you look at some of the signs
that you see,
you see some of the folks are br
up the pavement
or rocks
possibly for throwing.
Yeah.
A lot of people say that
this is just so much anger now
towards the government of Emmanu
that they are going to continue
to go on the street.
You can feel that anger here rig
If you look behind me,
you can see here
there's another big standoff
that's going on here right now
between the riot police
and some of the protesters.
You can see that's
why that's sort of the way
that all of this has gone.
Another one of those flashbacks.
That's sort of what's been going
We're going to go to the side
to make sure we're sort of out o
of some of these projectile show
that are flying. But oops,
as you can see,
a lot
of stuff flying through the air
as at least on the fringes.
Of this protest.
Things are getting a lot more
violent, Don.
And Fred, as long as you can sta
Let me ask you one more question
As we see the smoke bombs
going back and forth, protesters
putting them toward
the law enforcement there.
You keep mentioning
this is on the fringes
of these demonstrations
how widespread exactly can you d
Are scenes like this in Paris no
Are there several city blocks
where there's smoke going up,
or is this really just in one pl
Well, I would say definitely
there's not a flash
where I would sit there to say,
good here,
guys here, but I can stay with y
it's on
several city blocks
or get up.
Back to you,
Fred.
Catch your breath, Fred.
Catch your breath if you can.
Catch your breath.
Let me just describe
what's happening here.
Catch your breath
and let me know you're okay in a
What's happening again
is a standoff on the streets of
You see law enforcement
there with protesters
at these various intersections.
This is something we have seen b
They have these sort of pitched
where the protesters,
they put these smoke bombs
right in the face of the law.
Enforcement,
and the smoke goes up into the a
and gets everywhere,
including in reporters eyes
and down their throats.
Fred, are you back with me?
I'm back. Okay.
You okay?
I'm back with you. I'm sorry.
I just got a full load of tear
gas in my face. Yeah, I got it.
Just a little tear gas.
Yeah.
So you were asking
me how widespread this is.
I if you look around me,
pan in the other direction,
you can see it's going off there
So it certainly is several city
where this is going on here in P
It's it's
basically one part of the demons
that has had these confrontation
with the police.
I still think from our vantage p
from what we've seen
the largest part of this
protest is very much peaceful.
It's almost like a carnival atmo
But you do have this on the frin
that is going on.
I think we're going to go over t
Let's walk over there
and see what's going on over the
But yeah, it is
definitely pretty, pretty big.
I mean, the area
where these clashes are going on
are definitely several blocks he
And if you look over there,
you can see that there are
in some cases, things
that have been set on fire
trashcans have been set on fire,
flash bangs that have gone off.
You can see some of our colleagu
here have had paint all over the
That's something
that's also being used now.
I think back there,
you can see some people are sort
essentially trying
to break down the window of a sh
there, I think.
So that is something that is
not completely
widespread here in the city,
but certainly that's going on in
large area.
As you can see, we've been walki
a little bit here
and, you know,
we just keep seeing scenes
like like these
as right now
you can see the windows of that
that have some
it seems as though
someone just tried to break them
and maybe has maybe not succeede
And again, a lot of people here
voicing their anger
at the French
president, Emmanuel Macron,
really taking that out here
on the street as the riot police
also countering all of that stuf
Fred,
you had mentioned that many of t
that you are seeing, that they a
describe the makeup of the crowd
Is this union driven?
Is this generationally driven?
Yeah,
that's that's
actually a really good question,
I think it's something
it's really important
to point out to our viewers
as we see
some of this happening again,
if we turn around, we can see th
the next confrontation
it's about to happen.
This is sort of guys
from what they call
the black bloc here,
as you can see, hurling some pro
towards the law enforcement
over back there.
But you're absolutely right.
It's the police are charging now
Let me just see if we have to
get out of the way
or the cops charging towards us.
Direction is for the second.
So we're right
in the middle of it, it seems, r
But as you were asking about the
sort of of the crowd here,
I think it is very important to
that there are
a lot of people from unions.
There are a lot of people
who, you know,
are you know,
have been working for a long tim
of sort of looking towards retir
but there are also a lot of peop
who are nowhere near
retirement age, very young peopl
And I think you can see
that here in the crowd.
And for them, yes,
this is about the pension
reform that everyone Macron is t
to get through
here in France
and has used these extra powers
to do just that. But it's also v
about, oh, so I got here, I got
Oh, no.
Oh.
All right, Fred,
catch your breath again, please.
Catch your breath again.
Get a drink of water.
Yeah, I'm back. Hi, John.
Yeah, I'm back now.
So sorry about that again.
But yeah, I mean, it's as you ca
if things continue to kick off.
But as I was just talking about,
a lot of these young people
are just extremely angry
at the way that this
we have to move back
because we're actually right
in the firing line of possible
rocks being thrown
or just extremely angry at the w
that Emmanuel Macron
is trying to push through
this pension reform.
They believe that it's undemocra
and you can really feel that thi
become about more
than just the pension reform.
It's become
about the way
that Emmanuel Macron's
governing in general
and a lot of people
are voicing their anger at that.
And if you look at a lot of the
signs that people are holding,
if you look at a lot of the chan
that we're hearing here on the s
there are a lot more generally
against Emmanuel Macron's govern
than they are specifically
against the pension reforms.
You do have those people from th
as you can see, some projectiles
Again, these are rocks.
People tend to break down the ro
some of the tarmac in the street
and then throw them at police of
and then very often
the police will counter
that with tear gas
and then charge forward.
It's useless.
All right.
Now, the police are moving back,
But as you can see, John,
I mean, some pretty violent scen
that are happening here
on the streets of the French cap
And again,
this is
you know, we always have to poin
this is not the majority of the
who are marching.
A majority of the people
You know,
they have their political concer
that they're trying to voice.
This is just a small part of thi
But it does show that there is
you know,
a big confrontation
going on, obviously,
with law enforcement here.
There's a lot of anger
by some of these protesters
against the police as well.
Police in this country
don't sometimes have some pretty
handed tactics.
And you can see there's
just a general anger at the auth
at the government
that is being voiced
by people of many ages.
And it is important to also poin
that there are
tens of thousands of people
that we've seen this morning
that are marching here today.
Presumably,
there'll be hundreds of thousand
marching throughout the entire c
And this protest movement
really hasn't much musky,
despite the fact that it's been
for such a long time. So I'm.